todos los cambios de fase que hemos
estado haciendo hasta ahora han estado
bajo condiciones de presión constante y
en particular en los problemas que
estaba haciendo con el cambio de fase
del agua en los últimos vídeos estaba a
una presión atmosférica y de yo me
estaba a una presión atmosférica de una
atmósfera es decir al nivel del mar y
bueno explicaré justo este diagrama en
un momento pero todos sabemos que en el
universo
la presión no siempre es constante
definitivamente no siempre es una
atmósfera una atmósfera es definida como
la presión al nivel del mar en la tierra
obviamente la presión varía enormemente
si vas a los planetas más pequeños oa
planetas más grandes o planetas que
tengan una atmósfera más densa o
simplemente estamos haciendo diferentes
tipos de aplicaciones que tratan con
gases líquidos y sólidos
este de aquí y este de aquí es lo que se
conoce como un diagrama de fácil déjame
ponerlo esto de aquí y voy a ponerlo con
este color es un diagrama diagrama ok de
fase de fase o fases fase
y hay muchas formas de este tipo de
diagramas de fase esta es la forma más
común que puedes ver en tu curso de
química o en algún examen estandarizado
o lo que sea pero lo que capta son los
diferentes estados que hay de la materia
cuando hacen la transición de acuerdo a
la temperatura y a la presión este
declive es el diagrama de fase del auto
y bueno solamente para entender un poco
lo que está pasando aquí en este eje
tengo la presión y en este eje tengo la
temperatura y lo padre es que este
diagrama te dirá en un punto dado si
estás trabajando con un sólido con un
líquido o con un gas de hecho aquí
tenemos algo sólidos déjame ponerlo
sólidos ok
ese es el estado sólido por acá tengo al
líquido a mí lo voy a poner con este
color aquí tengo al estado líquido un
líquido
ok y por acá tengo al estado gaseoso así
que le voy a poner con este color
gas gas de lujo y esto está muy padre
porque por ejemplo si te digo que estoy
a cero grados celsius que estamos justo
como por acá estoy a cero grados celsius
antes de ponerlo así 0 grados ok y estoy
a una presión de una atmósfera bueno
pues si te das cuenta vamos a llegar a
este punto de aquí a los 0 grados
celsius y a la presión de una atmósfera
estamos en este punto de aquí que de
hecho es el punto límite entre el sólido
y el líquido aquí cuando tengo una
presión de una atmósfera correcto han
dejado ponerlo más o menos así llegamos
a este punto de modo que esto coincide
con nuestra noción tradicional de cuando
el hielo se congela o se derrite a cero
grados
y bueno si ponemos una presión más alta
supongamos que subimos esta presión
llegamos no sé a este valor y este valor
me da este punto de aquí y supongamos
que estamos no sé se me ocurre a diez
atmósferas ok
imagínate que estamos a diez atmósferas
que es lo que está pasando
bueno la presión atmosférica sube y
entonces si nosotros pensamos que esta
es la transición
de sólido a líquido lo que me está
diciendo este diagrama es que la
temperatura va a bajar dicho de otra
manera que con una presión más alta la
temperatura a la cual el hielo se
derrite
va a bajar y de igual manera si ponemos
una presión
más pequeña por ejemplo si nosotros
vamos a ver que está a una milla de
altura la presión es menor porque
tenemos menos de la atmósfera por encima
de nosotros bueno puedes darte cuenta
que si tenemos un valor menor a una
atmósfera entonces el punto de
congelación será menor no sé supongamos
que estamos aquí y nos da este valor que
supongamos que es mayor a un grado no lo
sé la idea es que no está completamente
dibujado a escala pero lo que quiero que
veas es que el agua se congelaría un
poco más rápido a una temperatura más
alta aquí en un lugar como temer a algún
lugar donde estaríamos no sé en el fondo
del mar muerto o en el valle de la
muerte o en algún punto por debajo del
nivel del mar en el planeta tierra
y ahora esta transición entre cualquier
cosa y bueno gas sabemos que estamos muy
familiarizados con ella recuerda que
estamos tratando con el agua y este es
un diagrama para el agua así que si yo
por ejemplo me sigo por aquí hablando de
una atmósfera ok vamos a seguirnos todo
todo todo todo todo todo todo derecho
quiero que te des cuenta que cuando
nosotros tenemos cero grados justo aquí
tenemos el punto en donde el agua se
congela es decir a una atmósfera en
donde el sólido se vuelve líquido y
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que si
nosotros seguimos sobre esta misma línea
de una atmósfera llegamos a este punto
de aquí en donde el líquido pasa a ser
estado gaseoso y nosotros sabemos a qué
temperatura es esto si nosotros bajamos
para acá y nos fijamos justo aquí en
nuestro eje de temperatura nos vamos a
dar cuenta que estamos a 100 grados
y esto porque ya sabemos que estamos a
una atmósfera y este punto en donde el
líquido se convierte a gas o agua
vaporizada lo podemos pensar también
como agua hervida todos esos nombres son
aceptables para pensar justo en esto
entonces nos fijamos que estamos a una
presión de una atmósfera pero ahora
imagínate que nos vamos a un pequeño
viaje y llegamos a la cima de amd se me
ocurre de la montaña everest y para eso
lo voy a poner con este color
imagínate que llegamos aquí donde
estamos en la montaña everest
ok llegamos al everest y qué va a pasar
y bueno pues tenemos una presión muy
baja en ese lugar estás de acuerdo así
que si está es la montaña everest y
bueno lo estoy poniendo aquí tal vez no
sea justo a esta altura recuerda que lo
estoy haciendo con un fin educativo pero
lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
nuestro punto de congelación bajo y
bueno de hecho también bajo nuestro
punto de ebullición justo este que tengo
aquí así que es mucho más fácil hervir
el agua en la montaña de vélez de lo que
es hervir el agua en el fondo de alguno
ceano o en el punto más bajo del valle
de la muerte o en el mar manto por
ejemplo y bueno justo la intuición que
hay detrás de todo esto es que si tengo
un líquido imagínate que por aquí
tengo las moléculas y déjenme ponerlas
así tengo un montón de moléculas en
forma líquida y que están en contacto
entre sí pero ojo están en contacto
entre sí pero no tienen la suficiente
energía cinética como para moverse
más allá de bueno de ellas están
fluyendo entre sí y están en una especie
de roce de unos contra otros una de las
razones por las que no solo bueno se
evaporan es que el aire está encima de
ellas hay una presión de aire y déjame
ponerlo más o menos así esto es justo lo
que hemos aprendido cuando hablábamos
acerca del pp es igual la nrc es decir
de los gases ideales si yo tengo por
ejemplo justo aquí tres moléculas del
aire es decir un montón de moléculas de
gas bueno la presión que están creando
que esencialmente es causada por su
temperatura y por su energía cinética
está haciendo están trabajando con estas
moléculas que tenemos aquí es decir
están sentadas ahí y rebotan y
esencialmente mantienen a estas
moléculas más pesadas para subir de modo
que les impiden separarse las unas de
las otras y esto hace que no se
conviertan en un gas así que a mayor
presión es más difícil para éstos
escaparse por otra parte si estamos en
el vacío
siendo justo esto mismo en la superficie
de la luna y supongamos que no hay
ninguna de estas moléculas que tenemos
aquí que no se tengan entonces cualquier
golpe ligero que se haga entre estas
hace que se vuelvan gas aunque esta
molécula está todavía un poco atraída
por aquí por esta otra siguen siendo
atraídas las unas con las otras pero
sólo un poco ya que no hay presión aquí
en la superficie de la luna esto podría
permitir a este tipo escapar y que se
vuelva directamente un gas así que
cuando bajes la presión es mucho más
fácil pasar del líquido a gas o incluso
si te das cuenta por aquí aún podríamos
pasar del estado sólido a gas y podrás
decir sal es que esto es un concepto
extraño de sonido a gas pero resulta que
si consigues bajar lo suficiente la
presión no sé supongamos como por aquí
si estamos hablando justo como por aquí
en este punto de aquí que bueno de hecho
seguramente cerca de aquí hay un vacío
entonces si tomaste el hielo y estabas
en la luna y estabas a la temperatura
correcta
qué bueno si te das cuenta debe ser una
temperatura negativa en grados celsius
no sé exactamente qué temperatura es
pero el punto es que tu hielo en la luna
iría directamente de hielo a gas y la
razón es porque aquí hay una enorme
cantidad de vacío entonces estas
moléculas podrían decir que hay todo
este espacio para llenar y si consigue
ser golpeado un poco entonces solamente
van a escapar y convertirse en gas y
podrás decir que esto es un fenómeno
extraño que sólo existe en la luna y
para rebatir ese comentario
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla dibuje
otro otro diagrama de fase que es este
que tengo aquí
este es el diagrama de fase del dióxido
de carbono que por cierto todo esto está
a tu alrededor y estás exhalando
mientras hablamos dióxido de carbono las
plantas en tu casa están inhalando
dióxido de carbono pero lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que el dióxido de
carbono a una atmósfera tiene un
comportamiento completamente distinto y
bueno por cierto cabe mencionar que
estas escalas están mal hechas o digamos
que estamos a una escala logarítmica
realmente de distancia que de aquí acá
es muy parecida a la distancia que está
aquí a camps pero realmente están
cantidades enormes de distancia y pasa
justo lo mismo am con esto de aquí aquí
estas dos escalas muestran muy cerca
estos dos valores pero de aquí acá hay
un montón de valores de por medio ahora
vamos a regresar a hablar del dióxido de
carbono y para eso obtengo este diagrama
de fase de aquí lo que quiero que veas
es que cuando nosotros hablamos de una
atmósfera en el dióxido de carbono es
decir estamos justo en este valor de
clint el dióxido de carbono cambia de
sólido a gas y déjame por cierto poner
que éste es el estado and déjame ponerlo
con este color éste es el estado sólido
soul y dom ok por acá estamos en el
estado el líquido líquido ok y por acá
estamos en el estado gaseoso
estamos en el estado gaseoso hablando de
el dióxido de carbono pero entonces
regresando a la idea de una atmósfera
imagínate que tú vives al nivel del mar
nueva orleans y bueno eres capaz de
conseguir que tu refrigerador esté por
debajo de menos 80 grados celsius bueno
lo que quiero que veas es que el dióxido
de carbono podría congelarse de hecho
puede ser que estés familiarizado con
eso si es que todavía lo utilizan para
las máquinas de humo o para efectos
visuales en el escenario esto es lo que
se conoce como el hielo seco ok vamos a
ponerlo el hielo seco seco es decir
dióxido de carbono congelado y si estás
en la presión atmosférica a nivel del
mar bueno tan pronto como consigas por
estar encima de los 70 y 8.5 grados
celsius negativos se sublima el gas es
decir que si nosotros hablamos de que el
paso de un sólido a un gas este proceso
se llama sublimación su ley
la sublimación es cuando pasamos de
sólido a gas y eso es lo que es el hielo
seco cuando lo ves no ves un hielo seco
líquido o no ves a bueno en presiones
estándar a dióxido de carbono en estado
líquido de hecho para obtener el dióxido
de carbono en estado líquido
necesitas conseguir estar por encima de
las 5 atmósferas es decir 5 veces por
encima de la presión atmosférica al
nivel del mar en la tierra y realmente
no vas a ver eso en condiciones
naturales en la tierra podrías ver esto
tal vez no sea en júpiter o saturno
donde tienes presiones muy grandes por
la gravedad y toda la atmósfera por
encima de ti en realidad no sé si en
júpiter haya dióxido de carbono pero
probablemente podrías ver esto en algún
otro planeta enormemente masivo que sea
un gigante gaseoso pero bueno en la
tierra este proceso es llamado
sublimación va directamente de sólido a
gas y es algo que puedes ver con el
hielo seco
quiero que veas dos puntos muy
interesantes por aquí que seguramente ya
los habrán notado el primero es este
punto de aquí que si te das cuenta es un
punto triple porque al menos en este
caso el dióxido de carbono a 5.1
atmósferas es decir más o menos justo
por aquí y a una temperatura de menos 56
grados celsius ok
tenemos este punto en donde el dióxido
de carbono está en un estado de
equilibrio entre el hielo el líquido y
el gas es decir es un poco de estos tres
si lo empujas en una dirección u otra es
decir puedes empujar la presión en la
temperatura irá en algunas de estas
direcciones del mismo modo para el agua
tenemos un punto triple dejamos subir un
poco esto tenemos un punto triple justo
aquí tenemos un punto triple con una
presión mucho más baja a la que estamos
acostumbrados a tratar esto es punto 611
kilo pascal es o simple y sencillamente
611 pascal es lo cual es 5
min
atmósferas 5 milésimas de atmósferas es
decir que si vas a 0.005 de una
atmósfera y vas un poco más arriba de 0
grados celsius un poquito más estás en
el punto triple del agua donde el agua
puede tomar cualquiera de estos tres
estados sólo en pocas solo en una u otra
dirección ahora el otro punto importante
que tenemos es justo este de aquí este
de aquí es el punto crítico porque si
nosotros aumentamos más la temperatura
más allá del punto crítico o subimos la
presión más allá del punto crítico antes
de poner que este de aquí es mi punto
crítico punto ok
crítico crítico y este punto crítico si
pasamos más allá de este punto entonces
estamos tratando con un fluido súper
crítico así que encima de esto tenemos
un han fluido súper crítico si nosotros
nos digamos por ejemplo aquí en el caso
del dióxido de carbono aquí también
tenemos este punto y si nosotros pasa
aumentamos la temperatura o la presión
bueno pues vamos a llegar a tener un
fluido flúor
done supercrítico super ok crítico
crítico y bueno que es un fluidos
supercríticos bueno si te das cuenta
tenemos una temperatura y una presión
muy altas es una temperatura tan alta
que bueno quiere ser un gas pero también
tenemos una presión tan alta que quiere
ser también un líquido y por lo tanto es
un poco de ambas de ello en el caso del
agua si nosotros subimos un poco de
nuevo en esta pantalla cuando nosotros
tenemos un fluido súper crítico es decir
agua supercrítica esta es usada como
solvente porque puedes imaginar que
tenemos un poco como el agua líquida en
la cual las cosas se pueden disolver
pero también estamos a una temperatura
tan alta que puede difundirse en sólidos
lo que es realmente bueno para conseguir
lo que sea que queramos limpiar y bueno
de alguna manera estamos hablando de un
fluido súper crítico que es algo de lo
cual sería bastante interesante pensar
quiero enseñarte estos diagramas de fase
iii que recuerdes que todo lo que hemos
hecho hasta ahorita tenía la presión
constante solo cambia la temperatura
pero ahora también puedes verlo desde la
otra forma si estoy por ejemplo nos en
aquí a 110 grados celsius ok y nos vamos
aquí al nivel del mar bueno nosotros
sabemos qué es lo que pasa justo en este
punto
nosotros tenemos agua en vapor pero
ahora imagínate que nosotros aumentamos
y aumentamos y aumentamos y aumentamos
la presión no sé
imagínate que estamos no sé cayendo en
un hoyo o entramos en el océano o lo que
se me ocurra entonces esta agua se va a
condensar de nuevo en un líquido aunque
estemos a 110 grados centígrados si yo
hiciera el experimento no sea justo por
aquí y entonces empezamos en este punto
y aumentamos la presión entonces vamos a
pasar de gas a sólido y de hecho en este
momento tendríamos en la sublimación
inversa a lo cual se le conoce con él
de deposición lo que quiere decir que
vamos a ir directamente de gas a sólido
suena impresionante no bueno así que
estos son los diagramas ordenados que te
dicen mucho sobre las diferentes
sustancias y te dicen qué pasa cuando la
presión o la temperatura cambia